Does the safe sleeve work the same way the heatron does for EFF protection?
No, so the heatron can help the EFFs that are coming off your phone to be less damaging to you.
The safe sleeve blocks EFFs. So two different things there. So you could use both a heatron. I have a
heatron on my phone and I use the safe sleeve. And I almost never put my phone up to my ear to talk.
I use my phone almost always either in the car or the speaker or speaker phone.
Not put it up to my ear. So you want to keep the EFFs away from you as much as possible.
The safe sleeve blocks the EFFs. So with the safe sleeve you can close the front face of it
and still talk on the phone up to your ear. It's going to block a good degree of EFFs.
And then if you want to completely block the EFFs from your phone, you could put it in what's
called a Faraday Cage. Faraday Cage is a term that it means that you're putting it in some
type of sleeve or compartment that blocks all EFFs, blocks all frequencies.
You will be able to receive phone calls or text notes in that. So we have those
they're super cheap. I think they're $15. There's fabric, double fabric,
sleeves that are a little bit bigger than your phone, that you can slip your phone into
and you're basically putting your phone to sleep. So you're not going to be able to receive phone calls
and you're not going to be able to receive text, but you will deduct it at EFFs from it.
So there's benefits to doing that at different times, like when you can still put the charging
port outside the phone, you don't have to close up the sleeve and you can charge your phone at night
without getting any EFFs, but it's better to keep it away from it.